a memorial service has been held in
Minneapolis for George Floyd the
african-american man killed by a white
police officer last month mourners stood
in silence for eight minutes and 46
seconds the amount of time it took Floyd
to die as the police officer held his
knee on his neck Floyd's death has
sparked protests across the u.s. with
demonstrators calling for an end to
discrimination and police brutality
civil rights activist Reverend Al
Sharpton said it was important to keep
fighting for justice Floyd story has
been the story of black folks because
ever since 401 years ago the reason we
could never be who we wanted and dream
to be in is you kept your knee on our
neck what happened to Floyd happens
every day in this country and education
and health services and in every area of
American life it's time for us to stand
up in George's name and say get your
knee oh well DW chorus punished F on C
Mon says in Minneapolis and joins us now
Stefan a powerful message there from
Reverend Sharpton did his eulogy offer
any sense of hope that George Floyd's
death could prove a turning point in
America's effort to address police
violence and racism yeah I think it
actually captured what the overwhelming
feeling is here when I say feeling then
I just because I don't have any other
and better word for it but what it is it
almost feels like there's a paradigm
change here and people feel there is a
paradigm change here and that's what
they're telling us they are done of
course with how things were they're not
looking back anymore at this in the same
way they did maybe just a days
ten days ago when mr. Floyd was killed
at this very place here for them it's
now forward and it's in a different way
forward and it's it's with a vision and
that vision is to change America not
just Minneapolis not just the police
department here and not just this state
Minnesota but the entire country and the
justice system in this country and many
many other things were a structural
racism is a daily occurrence to them ten
days after George Floyd's death what's
the situation on the streets of
Minneapolis Minneapolis it's like in any
or in most other states now the violence
is pretty much gone here in Minneapolis
entirely gone as far as we know it's
peaceful protesting it's forwarding the
cause it's people think they are and
understand themselves as being part of
the movement now in other states in the
United States you you have the pictures
we all see the pictures there is the
occasional run in because of a curfew
break with police but compared to what
it was like about a week ago here this
is peaceful protesting this is
furthering a cause this is being part of
a movement people say and not letting up
when they say no justice no peace they
really mean it president Trump's
response to George Floyd's death and the
ongoing protests Stephan has drawn
fierce criticism could it affect his
chances of re-election in November I'm
sure that this is a possibility
the president's poll numbers are in the
basement are Orrin heading actually
below floor ground at the moment at
least that's what the latest poll
suggests however there has to be
something said about
a president who failed to actually grasp
what is going on in America right now
and does not exert any leadership for
those people here because that's what
they are saying the president is missing
in action basically he's not taking any
leadership he's not showing any empathy
he does not really understand what is
going on and what is necessary for
America to happen this is hurting in
their minds him definitely for in his
reelection bit and his reelection
chances now having said that I don't
think the president had many friends
here before anyhow but he definitely
didn't make any year with being the law
and order or self proclaimed lauren
order president john thank you very much
that was DW Stefan Simmons there in
Minneapolis protesters have taken to the
streets of many cities across the United
States as Stefan mentioned GWS Alexander
phenomena has been following one man
who's attended rallies in Washington DC
every day to demand justice and an end
to police violence he's angry but he
hasn't lost hope taking to the streets
every day Kamal Hajj is one of the
activists at the heart of the protest in
Washington riding his bike across the
city kamal doesn't recognize his
hometown now dominated by a heavy police
and military presence for him it doesn't
feel safe he's had many guns pointed at
him he says from people wearing a badge
they will come up and be like let me see
your hands
and I will show my hand and then a way
trick questions like let me see your ID
which requires me to reach in my pocket
then he might pull a gun and be like let
me see your hands and you've like you
just ask my ID I'm getting my ID but
then they continue to be hostile and
aggressive and then eventually though
eggs can he Pat me down and stuff like
that that's what it means to be black in
America he tells me 52 years after the
killing of Martin Luther King
Jr like then this seems to be a
watershed moment for the US but what
makes this moment so dangerous is the
man in the White House came out says and
Donald Trump is litter he wants a war
because if he can start a civil war then
guess what he can stay in office for a
little while longer so he wants this war
he wants it to kick off like this he
wants a martial law he really wants
everyone act completely out of control
so he can have a purpose for his actions
in a city center they are marching again
Kemal is an electrical contractor but
since their pandemic started there's
been no work for him he tells me
together with his friends he's devoted
all his time to peaceful protests they
don't support the looting and burning
but understand that many young people
are bored and angry and used violence to
get the authorities attention you gotta
let people do what they do it now you do
your peaceful thing you do your knob
peaceful things because either way
Bob still out here trying to make an
attraction and something a few blocks
from the White House more and more
federal forces arrive many people here
are angry seeing the National Guard
being deployed against them the exchange
gets heated because you know you look at
these people as people like you want to
be considered a human yourself but then
you treat other humans as if we're
animals or some sort I just got really
upset it's not for some protesters leave
fearing the police could use tear gas or
rubber bullets against them again but
Kemal and his friends stay regardless of
what might happen
I think the patience is the best portion
for us to stay afloat to continue this
for long
long term thing because you know it's
gonna take a long time for this actually
be corrected he says he's never felt so
energized and exhausted at the same time
justice for George Floyd that's what he
wants and a real change in America well
here in Germany chanseong inimical has
been reacting to the death of George
Floyd and it's aftermath she criticized
president Trump's leadership style but
she also acknowledged that Germany too
has problems with racism the murder of
George Floyd is horrific
racism is horrific and u.s. society is
very polarized I think the politicians
should aim to unite and to reconcile I
think the president Trump's style of
politics is very controversial that's
clear racism has always existed but
unfortunately it exists here in Germany
too we should put our own house in order
and hope that enough people in the US
will move forward with peaceful protests
well what George Floyd's final legacy
will be
we cannot say but we can say tonight
that the impact of his death has the
potential to fundamentally change
American society and with its many
societies around the world an inflection
point as some have said or it could
become one of many points in a long
continuing staccato of racism and police
brutality in America my first guest
tonight says that the impact will be a
lasting one of change in her latest book
presidential black Americans and the
president's Margaret Kimberly examines
the role of all 45 US presidents in
America's relationship with race
Margaret Kimberly is a peace and justice
activist and editor and senior columnist
for black agenda report a news and
opinion website and ready a program miss
Kimberly joins me tonight from New York
City this is her first time with us on
the day MS Kimberly it's good to have
you here with us tonight if you were
delivering the eulogy for George Floyd
today
what would be the first sentence I would
say that since he was killed 10 more
black people have died at the hands of
police in this country it was horrific
to see this man being murdered and that
spurred protests about his death
obviously but about many in justices in
this country police violence being just
one among them and the revulsion was so
strong that for the past week for more
than a week now there have been constant
protests all over the country not just
restricted to minute
Minnesota so he this man who nobody knew
an ordinary working person has become a
touch point for millions of people
around the world and we have to honor
his memory by getting justice for him
but also getting justice for the many
nameless people who are killed but not
on camera so we don't know their names
but we know that they exist you talk
about justice all four of the police
officers involved they now face charges
Derek Chauvin he faces second-degree
murder charges which means intent to
kill the Attorney General of Minnesota
however has warned that it is hard to
convict the police what do you say to
that
well it's hard to convict the police
because prosecutors usually don't want
to convict them they get a ninety nine
percent conviction rate for everybody
else if they have the same commitment to
putting police away as they do for
anyone else then he can be that they the
four of them can all be convicted and
cops have been convicted but there has
to be a commitment to do it there has to
be a seriousness there has to be a
commitment to first of all making them
know that they they can be punished that
they can't get away with it this
happened because this cop assumed and he
wasn't wrong actually he assumed that
nothing would happen to him because
that's the case 99% of the time so mr.
Ellis Ellison who was a former
congressman by the way needs to step up
his game he needs to I think he's trying
to lower expectations because he's
afraid of what a jury will do but he
needs to do his job as the Attorney
General in the state of Minnesota and
make sure they're convicted they do it
all the time for everyone else the u.s.
President Donald Trump we understand was
not invited to today's memorial service
what role in your opinion what role does
he play in the events that we have seen
in the past week well he it's
interesting police murder didn't start
with Trump
we should not act as though Trump is
some sort of outlier he only became
president three years ago January 2017
and we had a problem with police killing
I'm gonna correct myself three people
every day one of those people will be
black a thousand people killed by police
every year and this happened before
Trump so I'm not gonna say he had any
role in the crime taking place but as
president he should give assurances to
the people that he will use the power of
his office to prosecute these cops
Barack Obama never used the powers of
the Justice Department to prosecute
these police if local law enforcement
fail the federal government can
prosecute and that's what we should
expect all presidents to do now Trump of
course has not been helpful in his
remarks and responding to these protests
he had this ridiculous stunt in front of
a church and his Attorney General was
tear gassing people to get the
the way so he could pose for a picture
with the Bible that sort of thing just
incites more violence and it gives
people the feeling that their concerns
are unheard so his response has been
very very unhelpful but Obama when
Baltimore erupted after a man named
Freddie gray was killed by police he
called the protesters thugs so III think
it's important not to think of Trump as
being so different yeah I want you to
take a listen to what former President
Barack Obama said just last night take a
listen
just remember this country was founded
on protest it is called the American
Revolution and every step of progress in
this country every expansion of freedom
every expression of our deepest ideals
has been won through efforts that made
the status quo uncomfortable and and
then we should all be thankful for folks
who are willing in a peaceful
disciplined way to be out there making a
difference there the former president
says it's even a part of American
history to protest yes but that's just
Obama's platitudes it's uh you know
which seems to be the only thing he can
say these days I guess because he's not
president anymore he can't get the best
speech writers but and I'm being
sarcastic obviously nobody needs him to
tell us that we have the right to
peacefully assemble nobody needs him to
tell us that it is the people who have
always made positive change in this
country we know that but he for eight
years he had the power he had the
authority to get these killer cops there
was a man here in New York City named
Eric garner and like George Floyd his
last words were I can't breathe and the
Obama Justice Department did nothing to
that cop and all he got was finally fire
from his job it took four or five years
or even that to happen so we don't need
to hear from Barack Obama he really
needs to just sit this out what about a
possible future president you posted
this photo on your Twitter feed today or
maybe it was yesterday I want to show
that to our viewers it shows the
presumptive Democratic candidate
presidential candidate Joe Biden taking
a knee inside the church and you wrote
that this is what you see when you stay
up past your bedtime and you say God is
punishing God is punishing you so tell
me what how is he punishing youth oh is
such a stupid picture I was just making
a joke I was like if I'd been in bed I
never would have seen it I mean Biden
gave this horrible speech to a in a
black church I believe it was in
Philadelphia and it was supposed to be a
response to George Floyd's killing and
the protest but Biden in his typical
manner made a mess of it and he he said
something weird about how police if
they're going to shoot people George
Floyd wasn't even shot but that police
should learn to shoot people in the leg
and not instead of in the heart I mean
the man is just he has some sort of
cognitive problem yeah but that's a
whole other story
but he posed for this picture with this
black congregation and he's uh on one
knee like : Kaepernick the football
player made famous and it was just
stupid
for Joe Biden of all people one of the
people by the way when he was a senator
who helped write the crime bill in the
90s and he bragged about writing up the
bill which puts so many black people in
prison and imprisonment begins with
interactions with police it begins with
police brutality and it can end in death
and is pretty shameful for this man to
hope that we forget all of that and pose
for a stupid photo op when people are
rising up in
righteous indignation yeah people are
rising up and with the protests began
last week when some of these protests
descended into violence and looting
there were calls for the protests to
remain peaceful I want you to take a
listen to what the mayor of Atlanta said
if you want change in America going
register to vote show up at the polls on
June 9th do it in November that is the
change we need in this country you are
disgraced in our city you are disgracing
the life of George Floyd and every other
person who has been killed in this
country miss Kimberly I know you've been
critical of of the mayor but I want to
ask you why why shouldn't she call for
protests to remain peaceful and for
people to vote for change at the ballot
box because if you look at what happened
in 2016 a lot of people are complaining
now about the way things are but if they
had to tell the truth they would have to
say that they didn't bother to vote well
I'm not going to tell people not to vote
but voting in this country usually just
end up with mediocre politicians like
the mayor of Atlanta it wouldn't have
been a problem if she had just asked for
peaceful protest but she went on this
rant about people disgracing the city
and she loved all protesters together
and this always happens there can be
legitimate protest there's always going
to be a small group of people who are
turn to petty thievery or something but
she lumped them all together and she
implied that every protestor was a
criminal and so all she if she wanted to
talk about peaceful protest that's all
she needed to do but to give people the
impression first of all it's just a lie
these elected officials including black
elected officials don't do anything to
protect their people there is nothing
about the act of voting that will end
police violence that's just a lie so we
need people like her who are just tokens
who are just figureheads who are give
the impression that black
we'll actually have some representation
we need them to frankly just shut up
right now
there was nothing in her comments that
was at all helpful to anyone well is
there a political party or a politician
in the US who you would say is reaching
out to people you know I think about
where I grew up in North Carolina rural
North Carolina you know there aren't
many middle-class North Carolinians
there anymore the poor whites the poor
blacks the poor Latinos they all have
more in common than they don't have in
common now but I don't see any political
party that's trying to reach all of them
and bring them together do you
unfortunately not there's the neither of
the Republicans or the Democrats do that
we have smaller parties like the Green
Party I'm a member of the greens and we
are growing and trying to reach out to
people but there was an effort in the
Democratic Party in one of the major
parties this year senator Bernie Sanders
his campaign sought to bring people
together he raised issues that have been
on addressed which I think have also
contributed to these protests and the
Democratic Party establishment got rid
of him they rigged the system against
him and they voiced a Joe Biden on us
that's what we get from voting and
that's what you get from the
establishment and that is why people
have learned they have learned the hard
way that electoral politics is not the
only means it's actually the worst means
of getting effective change one of the
things I hope that after in the
aftermath of these protests and the
police trial I hope that people remember
that and turn to themselves and start to
remain in solidarity develop solidarity
with one another and seek out non
electoral means of change because the
system has made clear it does not want
real involvement from people it does not
want any talk of change at all well if
it doesn't want any change then do you
believe that American society
can ever become colorblind and become
what the founding fathers proclaimed
that all men are created equal
well the founding fathers were a bunch
of hypocrites they didn't believe
anybody was equal they were mostly
slaveholders so I don't think we should
look to them but what they said at the
time the miss miss Kimberly what they
said but they said at the time there was
revolutionary for the way people thought
then I mean what about bringing it into
the 21st century and having everyone
equal do you think we can reach that we
can it was revolutionary for them but we
America can't change Without Really I'm
gonna say really revolutionary change
for everyone there has to be fundamental
change in this country first of all
there has to be a recognition that these
crimes have taken place over the
centuries and then we can once there's
honesty and once there are real
mechanisms in place to get rid of
inequality to get rid of the police
state to get rid of mass incarceration
once and for all to do justice by the
people in many different ways to bring
real democracy they let us vote but we
rarely get what we want even if the
person we vote for happens to win so yes
we can have a non racist society but it
will be it's a lot of hard work and we
can't do it with platitudes and and
phone enos from politicians Margaret
Kimberly editor and senior columnist for
black agenda report miss Kimberly it was
a pleasure talking with you we
appreciate your time tonight in your
insights come back again I certainly
hope to thank you very much
[Music]
what Donald Trump's threat to send in
the US military to deal with civil
unrest in the US has been met with a
stiff rebuke Trump's former defense
secretary Jim mattis has accused the
president of trying to divide America
and even his current Pentagon chief mark
Esper has said that he does not agree
with Trump's threat to send in troops
police in riot gear continued to watch
over crowds gathered near the White
House they've become a constant presence
here in Washington since George Floyd an
African American was killed in police
custody last week on Monday police
forcefully drove back protesters in
order to enable President Trump to visit
a nearby church before he stood outside
since John's Bible in hand he had
threatened to deploy the military to
quell the unrest if a city or state
refuses to take the actions that are
necessary to defend the life and
property of their residents
then I will deploy the United States
military and quickly solve the problem
for them thousands of National Guard
troops have already been called up
but Trump is facing a backlash from all
sides in a blistering attack on the
president Trump's former defense
secretary Jim mattis has accused him of
dividing America
he's also criticized Trump for even
considering using active-duty troops for
law enforcement meanwhile Trump's
current defense secretary Marcos bear
has opposed the use of military force
the option to use active duty forces in
a law enforcement role should only be
used as a matter of last resort and only
in the most urgent and dire of
situations we are not in one of those
situations now even general Milley the
highest-ranking figure in the US Armed
Forces has issued a statement reminding
the military that they swear an oath to
support and defend the Constitution and
the values embedded within it and that
it also gives Americans the right to
freedom of speech
and peaceful assembly as this apparent
rift between the president and his top
brass emerges protests continue across
the US